you play ray Romano's husband and
everyone I'm sorry
yes River Mon his wife when I said
Holly's a very good actor you were
terrific by the way as the father no you
play Ray Romano's wife and he is
physically I mean he's a big guy and in
the scenes you have together he he
dominates physically but you completely
control him and take over with the force
of the persona the character your plan
well I you know but here's the thing
about Ray and you know this about Ray
he's extremely humble he's like a really
humble guy neurotic I mean great right
um no I mean he's incredibly he's got so
so much humility and he's such a great
listener that he doesn't lead with any
kind of dominance
um and he you know he's not a really
machismo guy right he's like a human guy
so no it's true I think drew I think
you're describing I mean I've known ray
for a long time not super well but well
enough and he's incredibly sweet but I
love the dynamic in this movie the way
your character and I should explain
Kumail is dating your daughter and then
breaks they have a nasty breakup then
she gets quite sick and that's where you
and and ray come into the picture
because you guys are coming to take care
of your sick daughter and you see this
guy who you are very suspicious of
because they had a nasty breakup
exactly I mean which which kind of you
know it speaks to the intimacy that I
have with my daughter which you know she
tells me everything so I know a lot of
the secrets that she's been through with
this guy who there was a nasty breakup
right but you know I was just gonna say
that Kumail and Ray both being such
preeminent stand-up comics are such
beautiful actors yeah you know and and
that's a difficult that's a difficult
combination yeah right to be able to
it's rare that someone can have both of
those
it really is and I saw them both you
know going kind of switching from one to
the other and it's kind of merging the
two talents together on the said it was
that was a little intimidating well I
can't believe you were intimidated by
anyone in performing realm but let's
take a look at this clip I think this is
when you're there with your daughter and
this is I think your first encounter at
the hospital
with wit with whom a male with Camille
let's take a look I know you guys said
that you don't need me this day but I
think I'm just gonna wait I mean you
guys broke up I'm not sure why you're
here you don't have to worry about being
committed to anything come out you
didn't want to when she was awake
there's no need to do it when she's
unconscious it's more complicated than
that you really don't have to stack them
in you have already done I just gonna
stay for a second is this seat okay
[Music]
is that lady still looking at me you're
not looking at someone is devastating
that was such a great choice to just not
even look at him
when you're talking to him it's just so
incredibly devastating
you